viele Menschen sind besorgt derzeit in
Deutschland auch aufgrund solcher
Vorfälle ein Mann sticht wahllos in
einem Regionalzug zwischen Hamburg und
Kiel auf Menschen ein zwei Männer
sterben erst 16 und 19 Jahre alt
Sebastian Geißler hier aus der
Bildpolitik sitzt neben mir und du hast
eine ganz klare Forderung ja ich muss
sagen ich bin nicht sehr begeistert wie
das Thema medial aufbereitet wurde von
einigen wenn man sich anschaut den NDR
Hamburg beispielsweise der zunächst also
die in den Hintergrund nicht genannt hat
die Nationalität oder Dieter Herkunft
verschwiegen hat und sogar bei Facebook
unter einem Post Hinweise verborgen hat
auf den persönlichen Hintergrund und die
Herkunft des Täters und sogar dann
gesagt hat als Nutzer gesagt haben warum
macht ihr das dann wird das so
aussprechen dürfen dass der Mann aus
Gaza stammt dann geschrieben haben naja
ähm das sei führe zu diskriminierender
Verallgemeinerung und viel
Interpretation man wurde die Seite
Freiheiten von Rassismus
und das sei auch keine Zensur sondern
diene dem Erhalt der Demokratie da muss
ich sagen also Journalisten die die
Realität da vernebeln die erhalten nicht
die Demokratie sondern die Sorgen
eigentlich dafür dass wir über diese
Probleme nicht offen sprechen können Sie
dadurch auch nicht lösen können und das
ist es in Wahrheit was auch Extremisten
stärkt das sorgt dafür dass Menschen
sich von diesem Medienmarken abwenden
und da sehe ich eine Gefahr wir suchen
Journalist hat aus der flüchtlingskrise
in der vergangenen Jahren nichts gelernt
das darf so nicht sein wir müssen offen
sagen wer diese Täter sind also Medien
lassen bewusst die Herkunft weg oder
beschönigen teilweise auch Vorstrafen in
dem Fall war das oder wurde ganz offen
einfach verborgen woher dieser Mann
stammt und man glaubt noch
offensichtlich das haben wir ja hier nur
mehr oder weniger schriftlich bekommen
vom Social Media Themen vom NDR Hamburg
dass man damit was Gutes tue und im
Grunde der Demokratie Hilfe da sage ich
das eine gravierende fehlanalyse das
sorgt dafür dass Menschen dann eher
irgendwie in irgendwelche
telegram-gruppen abrutschen und so
weiter und es sorgt vor allem auch dafür
dass die Politik nicht in Wahl und kommt
diese Probleme mal zu erkennen und zu
lösen denn wir müssen diese diese Täter
auch offen benennen wir müssen auch
sehen was sind das eigentlich für
Gruppen das sind ja Leute die da diese
Profile ähneln sich ja wir sehen auch
wenn der Mann schon ungefähr 12 mal
vorher polizeilich erschien in der
Scheidung getreten ist unter anderem
übrigens mit einer Messer Tat und wenn
er vorher in Haft saß und dann rauskommt
und eine solche Tat begeht dann läuft er
nun offensichtlich etwas schief in
unserem Land und das müssen wir
aufarbeiten und auch politisch eine
Lösung zu führen aber ich habe eine
frage
also die Herkunft wieso ist da diese
Herkunft so wichtig ist könnte er jetzt
auch ein deutscher machen also ich frage
jetzt mal wirklich das hat er was mit
hier oben zu tun das hat jetzt auch
einen Deutscher sein kann das ist
tatsächlich möglich aber wir sehen ja
gerade bei dieser Art von taten die sich
ja auch häufen das sind vielfach
Menschen die irgendwie traumatisiert
sind vielfach Menschen die eigentlich
auch gar keinen ähm der hatte wie sagt
man so eine seltsame
Aufenthaltsgestattung da weil aber auch
seine Staatsbürgerschaft irgendwie
unklar war ist also Palästinenser da ist
die Frage an wen könnte man so jemanden
ausweisen aber das sind Leute die laufen
hier im Grunde
frei rum und wir stellen aber eigentlich
eine Gefahr da und das ist eben das wo
man politische ran muss und sagen muss
wie kann man wie kann man solche Leute
dann irgendwie auch in Schach halten die
offenbar ja eine Gefahr von Leben sind
also wenn du deine Steuer nicht zahlst
wirst du schneller eingebuchtet ewig
also ein Typ muss man einfach so sagen
das ist vielfach so ja das ist echt
super blanke sie verstehen aber warum
ist der NDR beispielsweise die Herkunft
verschweigt sie sagen Täter ist Täter
also ich bleibe schon bei Täter ist
Täter natürlich klar traumatisiert kann
aber auch in Deutschland kann Italiener
es kann jeder sein ist es egal aber es
stimmt schon ich glaube dass da so eine
Lücke ist dass die dass die gar nicht
mehr klar kommen mit diesen ganzen
Leuten also die wandern da so durch die
sind einfach die wissen gar nicht mehr
wie sie mit sowas handeln sollen und das
da wirklich der so wahnsinnig ist und in
den Zug ich bin ja heute in Zug
eingesteckt
hergekommen was hatten sie für ein
Gefühl ja ein schlechtes weil an sowas
denkt man wirklich nicht also du steigst
in so einem Zug ein sitz da und dann
kommt so ein Irrer mit so einem Messer
das ist ja Wahnsinn also es ist ja echt
brutal ja total ist das sicher aber der
in diesem Punkt war es ja so also wenn
es dazu führt das jetzt tatsächlich hier
genannt wird das ein Palästinenser und
die Menschen denken oh Gott die
Palästinenser die sind sehr sowieso alle
messerwütig und oder Arabisch
stimmenische Menschen dann wäre das
natürlich eine ganz furchtbare
Konsequenz davon da kann ich den NDR
wenn Sie das den bezweckt haben ein
bisschen verstehen aber hier geht's ja
um was eigentlich anderes der Mann hat
ja im Jahre 2015 glaube ich hier ist er
hingekommen nach Deutschland es gibt
einen Asyl Beitrag der der wird jetzt
seit acht Jahren bearbeitet und ist
nicht entschieden worden in der
Zwischenzeit gab es mehrere
straffälligkeiten von ihm du hast es
erwähnt einmal hat er mindestens einmal
schon ein mit einem Messer vorher schon
jemanden anderen einen anderen
Obdachlosen oder in einer
Obdachlosenunterkunft nicht nur bedroht
sondern auch verletzt da frage ich mich
schon warum ist dieser Mensch dann hat
sie warum ist dieses Asylverfahren noch
offen ganz einfach ist das eine die
Begründung die heute gegeben wurde war
naja von einem Experten den kann man ja
gar nicht abschieben Gesetz wenn man
wollte weil palästinien Palästina oder
gar seid ja noch nicht mein Flughafen
also man könnte ihn sicherlich irgendwo
anders in die Nähe
oder sonst wohin bringen und
möglicherweise darüber bringen oder in
andere Gebiete drumherum das ist
natürlich so dass die Menschen überhaupt
keinen Verständnis mehr dafür haben und
das ist die Distanz vom Staat noch
weiter entfernt
wir haben gerade angesprochen die lange
vorstrafenliste haben da für sie die
Behörden versagt ja natürlich also ich
meine im Grunde genommen ist das ein
Unding das so ein Mensch mit diesen
Vorstrafen mit dem was er verbrochen hat
ja einfach noch draußen ist und so
agieren kann ich meine natürlich müsste
man sich alles im Detail anschauen auch
die richterlichen Entscheidung und so
weiter aber wir sehen ja immer wieder
dass es Probleme dieser Art gibt und da
muss man sich fragen woran liegt das wie
kommt das ja die Frau lang war das ja
gerade schon gesagt wenn auf anderer
Seite jemand ja was relativ
geringfügiges macht und dann erlebt man
mit Hunde auch die Härte der deutschen
Gerichte und dass ich also schon ein
massives Problem und die Frage ist eben
ja warum ist das und natürlich muss man
auch davor ja waren oder vorsichtig sein
dass man nicht alle Menschen die hierher
kommen und Schutz suchen verurteilt das
ist natürlich nur ein ganz ganz ja
kleiner Teil aber super es gibt ein
reales Problem und dieses Problem darf
man nicht verschleiern oder bin ich auch
bei Ihnen wenn Medien hier
ja einfach nicht korrekt Berichten aus
falscher Zurückhaltung und dann haben
wir auch einen Bruch mit der Realität
und
wenn sie ja sich umhören mit den
Menschen auf der Straße sprechen und
auch da aufnehmen was die Leute einfach
aus ihrer persönlichen
persönlichen Erlebnissen sehen dann ist
sehe ich da eine riesengroße Lücke
zwischen idealer Berichterstattung und
der Realität
wichtig hältst du die Herkunft der Tesa
die Nennung der Herkunft der Täter kann
man damit wirklich etwas verändern oder
für das vielleicht nicht noch mehr
Vorurteile nur die nur die Herkunft
führt natürlich Vorurteile weil man sagt
da ist ein Araber jetzt eine ganz platt
also jemand der sich nicht so intensiv
damit befasst der wird sagen sticht
wieder drauf da habe ich doch gesagt
alle zurück und sowas warum haben wir
diese Menschen überhaupt nicht fing mit
der flüchtlingskrise an jetzt haben wir
diesen ganzen Salat so ist die relativ
einfache Betrachtung des Problems wofür
schon bin eine genaue Betrachtung der
Personen die der Täter ist und wenn es
da die teils gibt die einfach einen nur
wütend werden lassen dass jemand
tatsächlich hier
wie dieser Mann
seit acht Jahren einen einen einen
duldungsasyl oder was auch immer Antrag
hier hat über den kann er entschieden
werden und wenn jemand dann mehrfach
straffällig wird und jemanden anderen
dann auch noch tatsächlich auch mit
einer Stichwaffe verletzt da muss man
sich doch die Frage stellen ist dieser
Mann hier noch willkommen man kann den
offenkundig ja auch gar nicht mehr quasi
ausweisen zumindest hat es keinen
vergleichbaren Pferde gegeben da muss
man sich als Innenministerin schon die
Frage stellen ob diese Regelung sinnvoll
sind oder ob man da noch irgendwas
ändern kann also die Details auf jeden
Fall und etwas und deswegen ist es ja
gut dass jetzt in Zukunft ich
hoffentlich dann schneller darüber
entschieden wird aber diese Kriterien
müssen auch so bedeuten dass jemand wenn
jemand straffällig wird dann auch
wirklich dann zurück muss in diesen
Fällen und das ist sie auf dem Kunden
nicht unterblieben und da hat man
versagt Sebastian stellt sich die
Politik die Fragen die Bilder Anna hier
gerade aufgeworfen hat nicht genug nicht
dringlich genug in mein Eindruck ist das
es hat ja auch nennt sich Weser unsere
Innenministerin drauf reagiert hat aber
im Grunde auch nur ihr genau gesagt das
ist eine schlimme Tat und so weiter man
ist dann immer sehr zurückhalten wenn es
darum geht sozusagen politische
Konsequenzen daraus zu ziehen da wird
dann schnell vorwerfen oder wird
irgendwas instrumentalisiert und wir
haben lange ja gehört das ist ja fast
ein Gefühl das Wort sogenannte
Einzelfälle man muss man sagen es häuft
sich schon sehen also es ist eine
bestimmte Täter Klientel die da diese
Probleme macht und wenn Deutschland ein
modernes Einwanderungsland sein will wo
wir Fachkräfte aus aller Welt und so
weiter dann müssen wir auch uns klar
machen wie wir bekommen heißen wollen
und wie wir nicht willkommen heißen
wollen und wenn einen ein
Aufenthaltstitel endet oder jemand auch
das ist übel Verfahren Abschläge ich
beschrieben bekommen hat und
Ausreisepflicht ist vollziehbar dann
muss er auch beweisen und dann müssen
unsere Behörden auch sicherstellen dass
so jemand unser Land wieder verlässt
aber ist natürlich auch eine Gefahr wenn
man jetzt nur auf diesen Ursprung wo
diese Leute herkommen wenn man dazu sehr
darüber redet dann entsteht ja beim
Bürger auch so eine Art Hass also das
heißt da laufen die dann so durch die
Gegend vielleicht auch gute die jetzt
aus Bagdad oder was weiß ich woher die
kommen und werden angegriffen das habe
ich alles schon gesehen
was wäre die Lösung es ist ja die Löcher
das Problem es gibt eben keine Lösung
weil es ist überall gibt es immer eine
dunkle Ziffer von Menschen es gibt es in
Deutschland es gibt in jedem Land aber
klar Deutschland hat natürlich immer
dieses Problem die Türen sind immer
offen man will ja nach außen zeigen man
ist jetzt nicht rassistisch man ist dies
nicht aber das ist so schwer das ist
einfach echt schwierig weil der Bürger
macht sich ja ein Bild und ich wette
jetzt nach dieser Geschichte wenn man
jetzt ein bisschen dunkelhäutig ist und
einem Zug rumrennen und ein bisschen
komisch aussieht wird man schon von der
Seite angeschaut also denke ich jetzt
auch so funktioniert der Mensch ja vor
allen Dingen muss man sich einfach auch
noch mal vor Augen führen die Schwere
der strafzahlen die da im Raum stehen
also wir reden aber hier nicht was weiß
ich von Schwarzfahren
genau also ich meine das ja das wiegt
wirklich richtig schwer und da muss man
einfach auch den
ja also Jugendämter die nicht ja also
oft genug in so ein Haus gehen wo ein
Kind irgendwie missbraucht wird das ist
leider derselben spielt die Frage ist
halt wurde das verpennt ja ich meine
dann ist einer zum Himmel schreiende
Inkompetenz auf Seiten der Behörden ja
oder gibt es andere Gründe was auch
immer aber ja das ist natürlich
unerträglich
ist natürlich völlig richtig was Frau
Blanco hier auch sagt also es sind
sozusagen die Leute rechts außen sagen
auch die sind alle so die müssen alle
raus und dann gibt's von links Leute die
sagen die von denen ist gar keiner so
oder darf man über die gegen die darf
man gar nicht sagen beides stimmt
natürlich nicht wir brauchen die
Realität betrachten wir als Medien
müssen das tun die Politik sollte das
tun dann kann man diese Probleme auch
lösen und dann kam Deutschland auch das
moderne Einwanderungsland sein das ist
ja sein will man setzt nämlich gerade
wie sie es ihm sagten Menschen auch
einer Lesart aus die vielleicht etwas so
aussehen als wenn sie von ja das in der
Familie Geschichte und so weiter das
sind oft die Leute die dann darunter zu
leiden haben oh da habe ich jetzt einmal
ein gewisses eine Beklemmung hier genau
wenn jemand so und so aussieht ähm das
heißt das ist etwas das beschweigen und
verschweigen ist auch was was dann
diesen rassistischen Tendenzen und
Wahrnehmung eher Auftrieb verschafft